oh yeah
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
what's up everybody thank you for
joining us another episode of dope as
usual podcast i'm your host dopaz yola
today guys we have another episode thank
you for joining us awesome guest i am
excited
super stoked to hear what you got to say
thank you everybody uh
introducing jaron wilson pro skater
entrepreneur thank you for coming
hell yeah thank you thank you man thank
you for coming today i like the way you
rolled up
i thought you rolled up on a board this
fool did too but i thought
i was like yo does everybody [ __ ]
skate oh you didn't see me i had
like a complaint you were rolling up on
a [ __ ] skateboard you know no one
drives
no we're right here in the middle of
yeah yeah that's here so we got you
um thank you for coming out of course
appreciate you so much for sure
um let's get right into it man yeah for
everyone out there
pro skater yeah still holding it on hold
on
oh man i've uh done my research a lot of
clips
i just do you ever look at yourself go
[ __ ] that was me
have you ever done that because i looked
you like yo i met this man
he's flying you're right you know what
it is kind of a little
you know i would have never thought you
know years ago that i would be you know
here still you know being a professional
skateboarder [ __ ] 30 years later
um no i definitely didn't you know
envision
myself you know doing that but yeah i
mean we're here and you know we're
enjoying it so
when did you uh first start skating i
mean we all first started skating and
then years later like no i'm
i'm serious i'm trying to escape when
did you first pick did you pick it up
and you were serious the right away
no i mean i think it was one of those
things it was just fun like it was like
a
you know a lot of kids in my
neighborhood were skating and and my
cousins so it made it easy for me to
kind of just
kind of be a lure to it so i uh yeah
they pieced make the
a board together for me when i was like
10 and ever since that i was just like
in love with it
see that's that was my question so
you're about 10 years old so you picked
it up and just kept running it never
stopped
yeah and when i stopped probably for
like a year or so and i rode bikes
you know what it'd be you know would do
you know at that time so
um that's probably around 11. i stopped
for like a year and then started back up
around around 12 or so
yeah yeah i saw um i googled some videos
i saw a video you
you look like you were 12 13 years old
man oh yeah definitely
i mean it's it's what i saw was all my
friends when i was younger like yo
you could be really good just stick with
that [ __ ] nobody ever did what you
obviously did
when did you start picking up and
realizing like yo i'm so much [ __ ]
better than everybody my age
um [ __ ] dude i think it was just one of
those things i just started picking up
tricks
like fairly easy and you know like i
think it was just it was so fun
so it was one of those things that was
so new so fun and
a lot of kids around me i had my close
friend western korea that kind of
definitely
motivated me just seeing him he was my
age it's not like a year younger
and yeah it was really easy to
you know go out with him and just you
know find these little spots around the
neighborhood and just you know have fun
the next thing you know we started
entering contests and then that's when i
kind of you know
seen that hey people are paying
attention they're asking me like hey you
want you know some wheels you want
the wheel sponsor or no so it was like
you know gradually kind of just
just happening you know without really
trying i guess yeah yeah you just i'm
good but you didn't realize how good you
were until people like yo could you ride
with this
you want to ride with our stuff exactly
with some wheels yeah really how about
that um i started probably like the
first time like around 14 i guess
yeah just entering high school it's
about to get sponsorships and [ __ ] yeah
but i was like
going into high school dude i didn't
even really like i didn't tell people i
was a skater i was like kind of like i'm
low-key about it you know
where you from uh san fernando valley
born and raised right here yeah
oh [ __ ] yeah it's the early 90s
you're skating not telling anybody but
then again early 90s when i was a kid my
mom gave me a stack of thrashers and
that's how i learned
about all the skating i mean i love
skating as a kid i just hate my head i'm
[ __ ] over hitting my head
i'm done with my tailbones being bruised
i'm [ __ ] over i started selling drugs
that's the route i went right right
that's the route i went but um as a kid
14 years old in high school you didn't
you weren't hyped on that [ __ ] no i was
super hyped but i was at the same time
it was like i had two different worlds i
had i was going to school and doing my
thing like you know had my school for
school homies and [ __ ] and then you know
after i would leave like on friday i
would just go kick it with my skate
homies you know and that would just be
two different worlds you know and i
never really mixed
both of them for some reason you know it
was just i was like
school at school and skating and skating
and i just you know kind of
rolled with it like that yeah really did
you skate with the kids around you or
were
were you having to go like you said on
the weekends you go to the skate friends
no i had like people that basically
uh going back again to the contest
atmosphere you know i ended up meeting
people
in in that arena which i ended up
hanging out with them
in on the weekends you know they would
come and pick me up say for
i hate the nicknames right but like eric
costan and tim gavin they would come and
pick me up on the weekends and i would
spend the weekend with them and we'd
skate and you know do that thing
and then um they would bring me home on
sunday and my mom you know would be
happy that i came home because i would
just sometimes i just didn't want to go
back to school you know but by the time
i was like ninth
tenth grade i was asking her like is it
cool if i you know
stay out dude we do home school or some
[ __ ] and she's like oh she got [ __ ]
two years left just finish the [ __ ] you
know what i mean
she was on you about it yeah did you
finish i did oh then
i mean that's all that matters totally
and totally but i'll say it's okay
that was the same situation with me
except like i said i want another route
friday night like cool i got this much
i'm gonna sell this i'll come back
sunday i'll see you later
and they know i knew what i was doing at
least you were doing it right i didn't
separate [ __ ]
right that's why my [ __ ] got it messed
up i didn't i
almost didn't finish school but so you
growing up in the 90s going
er i just i know you're like don't want
to name drop but you have to remember
looking outside yourself uh fans looking
like yo
totally you know you are right it's like
it's on that
status of i'm sure they're costing on
the weekends we're chilling we grew up
we came up together so
how was it growing up knowing like all
of you are about to be the [ __ ]
[ __ ] for me it's kind of crazy because i
was seeing them before i got to
even you know get to that little realm
of hanging with them you know so
um it was bizarre for me you know i was
just like
because like i said everything happened
really fast and to see my peers that
were in videos and now i'm [ __ ]
chilling with them
i mean yeah it was kind of bizarre but
then once everything started happening
i'm like yeah here i am like you know
that's what we do i arrived you know
which was rad you know but these guys
were just you know obviously pioneered
it
right before i was able to you know
actually be a part of it you know
so it was cool man that's cool man yeah
like i always
wanted i always want to ask that
question like recent guests how did you
feel when you first real
it's just for me skating is a thing i
really really loved as a kid i just
until i was like 14 or 15 i realized yo
you are not [ __ ] down to hit these
stairs you're not down to go offload i'm
like i'm not
right not [ __ ] down all my friends
are badasses
we had one one sponsored skater in
merced where i'm from and he was the man
he could do 360 flips and hard flips
that was the [ __ ] you know yeah the
hometown like
no he could hit the whole rail
[ __ ] that's what it was but
you're you're down here you're around a
bunch of legends man
i think it's when you're in it it's like
kind of hard to be like you know [ __ ]
this is so rad but don't get me wrong i
was
super like humbled and blessed to be in
this situation but i think when it's
happening it's just like you know
you're not you're in the moment yeah
exactly that's it but
so you're in the 90s i know i keep going
back to it but that's
that just reminds me of childhood man
totally it just reminds me of being
just grab a board you'll be back at five
or six hours
you know come back and your elbows are
[ __ ] everything hurts no phone so you
know
like you know i'm trying to get home
with you you're like you're gone all day
the sun's going down [ __ ] she's gonna
beat my ass that was the that's how i
always imagined being a kid but
you guys are the ones i was looking at
like wow these [ __ ] kids are really
doing he's not even older than me
not even much you know that's how i was
thinking because as a kid
i'm looking at thrashers it's nothing
but white dudes i didn't see nothing but
white dudes right now
so when i was a kid i was i'm from a
mexican ass town
and it happened you're short of [ __ ] bro
you're not a [ __ ] tall white kid
it ain't gonna [ __ ] happen totally so
i think that was another reason why i
kept it on the little in high school as
well i didn't want people all in my
business you know what i'm saying like
i dressed a certain way and like it
didn't look like i was a skater you know
i
you know i was wearing nikes and [ __ ]
and just so i think that's
kind of like maybe wouldn't give people
an inkling that i was a skateboarder you
know what i'm saying so was it more like
i'm proud yet i don't want you to talk
[ __ ] about me
how would you feel about why would you
hold it because it's yeah because i mean
there was a stigma about skaters to a
certain degree you know what i'm saying
so yeah
i didn't want to hear anything from
anybody you know i'm saying mind you
i'm actually doing my [ __ ] thing to
be honest and like i got sponsors and
[ __ ] and don't get me wrong like
i should be proud of that which one
which i was but i ain't trying to go
around
the high school holding the flag like
[ __ ] i'm a pro skater no i'm not
a pro skater but sponsored and [ __ ] so
i just kept it on low and people that
knew knew you know what i'm saying it
was just
i think in hindsight like yeah i should
have been more you know vocal about it
and been like yeah i'm a skater and this
and that but
and not even more of like hey what's up
man i'm a pro skater nothing like that
right what do you do ice skating [ __ ]
totally and i said like my close friends
they knew it was they knew they knew
what's up yeah because then
like they'd be like what are you doing
this weekend i'm like i'm gonna be gone
like
i'm coming skating yeah i'm saying but
what a transition from the 90s to now
you you go in your pro skater every
[ __ ] person in the school knows
you're pro skater
right because that shit's bad and once
you got accepted yeah
i should see and at that time yeah it
definitely wasn't like how it is now get
chased off and [ __ ] with a sk
yeah you can change something anywhere
every every there's so many skaters now
it's insane
i i honestly when i googled that [ __ ] i
was like you know who's who's the
populist gate is right now besides nigel
houston like
the ones coming up there's hunch
yeah it's crazy but social media has
changed everything for every
for every aspect of every for every
skateboarder but and i i tell them i'm
very advocate on like hey dude if you're
not on social media and you're trying to
really
do something with skating you're
tripping you better be on social media
because if you're not you're not you're
you you're that's the way to get
recognized yeah you know you used to
make skate videos yeah now it's make
them and put them on the [ __ ]
internet man what are you doing yeah not
just passing out tapes to your friend
like check this [ __ ] out
pretty much that was fun man i do
remember the fisheye all the kids at the
park oh man i missed that yeah it was
good times man
yeah definitely definitely um so
like i said earlier i met you through
omaha ratchet man yeah when we met
i think we were we went to a dispensary
right yes
yeah i think it's studio city i forget
the name of this i remember where it's i
don't remember the name of the spot
yeah but it was a studio city yeah so
that's what i was gonna bring up and
that's why i asked you still smokes i
don't wanna i do
box people and [ __ ] i feel bad you know
i want to ask first
for sure i'm so used to i'm like a a
bong smoker
are you ready that's how i smoke but i
don't smoke you know
so we gotta do this i'll do this too i
honestly i don't bust the bongs out
because most people aren't bong smokers
i love it i i really
i got you before you leave a hundred
percent there's
bongs go lower over here i know i just
seen a big shipment going out
thank you um so with diamond let's get
into that
for everyone out there you're part of
diamond or
formerly or still well i'm co-owner
co-owner co-owner of diamond splash
still right
yep how did that come about because i
first time i heard it
i was like all right cool the pretty
mexican kids with the diamonds in their
ears wear diamond and
as a snake raptor on a diamond because
in merced there's no [ __ ] skaters
right there's like six and all of them
are wearing etnies still
they're not wearing diamond back then
right because i saw diamond and thought
what [ __ ] brand is it then i found
out it's a skate company and i
automatically went okay that's tight
it's getting popular it's that popular
skate
what tell me more right so how did that
come about um well
nick touche was pretty much the you know
the the main guy of diamond supply co
and um he started a boat company and i
definitely was just fond of the designs
and everything
and we've known each other for quite
some time and i you know i
asked him one day if like i could you
know possibly get down and
luckily it was there was a a a way for
we
to to figure this out so we figured it
out and
you know i was able to join in the team
and you know it was a
beautiful thing this happened in 2009 in
march
so that was like yeah pretty much almost
over 10 years over 10 years yeah i was
saying oh
almost 10 [ __ ] over 10 years ago yeah
man wow so what did you guys do to it
just
groundwork uh just putting in because i
know it started off as
hardware right totally and then i mean
the clothes [ __ ] explode
of course yeah like i said they all went
back to design that you know obviously
um nick was producing at the time um and
then he was just really keen on social
media then
you know so he was really kind of kept
his ear to the street and
um one thing led to another and it just
kind of blew up overnight you know
and um yeah went from just hardware like
a hardware company to like a damn
streetwear brand for the most part
one of the biggest ones i've i've ever
seen yeah honestly
yeah does that mean some merced and
you're wearing it that she got big cause
we're a poor ass town
right there you know brand dope [ __ ]
over there especially at our mall
right you know right right um so how was
that man how did you i mean
you're going from pro skater now you're
an adult right you know i mean or adult
you're now into your almost to your 30s
at this point when diamond gets [ __ ]
big
you're growing up and now you have a
streetwear brand on your hands how did
how'd you take that in i mean look dude
it was like i think the right place at
the right time and like the
timing was amazing bro i think around
like i said around 2010
2011 is when really things started to
change dramatically
you know from a [ __ ] like a 1.3
million dollar company to like a you
know
i think a 25 million dollar company in a
matter of two years and then
yeah it just it just was happening so
fast and it's just like
how do you control it you know what i'm
saying we are two like skateboarders at
the end of the day
you know yeah it's amazing um but to try
to control that growth is
pretty insane you know what i'm saying
so we we weren't able to control the
growth and we just grew and grew and you
know
uh got to a point where we were really
you know doing really well
you know and um what do you do when you
when you
continue to do well i mean you gotta you
gotta kind of change and you know change
the format of what you're doing because
things don't stay the same you gotta
kind of you know work with the time
exactly
and um yeah man it was a it was a wild
and fun ride i can't say that that's for
sure
that's i mean that's how i me i meant
omar through diamond [ __ ] yeah he was
working with for a while yeah
i mean uco we just got this warehouse
when i first saw that diamond warehouse
it was unbelievable i can't believe that
people actually threw that [ __ ] together
like that yeah what there's a skatepark
in there it's a fun house
yeah man that's a fan that's a real
fantasy factor
it was it was like the second fantasy
factory it was sick dude
i the first time i ever went in there
did she was it like the conference room
was a giant [ __ ] night was it
like a class like sculpture or some [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah i mean
just the the way that nick designed the
whole office is amazing it's definitely
like
eye candy for sure you know to everybody
that came in there you know
yeah yeah now but that's it that's
awesome dude i had to bring that up just
because it's
it seriously took over the world for a
while yeah man like i said it was uh
one of those moments in time that you
know you wish you could kind of hold on
to forever you know but then again
for that high amount of traffic and
waking up every day on your phone doing
it it's kind of nice to go
got you paid us sick all right chill
yeah
because it's been five years man it's
been five years non-stop
let's slow down a bit and i mean at the
end of the day you know you always want
to be
continue to be successful you know yeah
of course but you know sometimes it's uh
it's real daunting it definitely could
take a toll on you for sure
non-stop for sure yeah yeah so i saw
another thing
i've been doing a couple of diamond
parties on fairfax uh with omar
you throw big ass poker games
yeah once a year during my birthday um
i've been doing it [ __ ] since i turned
30.
so damn this last year we obviously
weren't able to do it
because of you know at least the
pandemic and everything but the year
prior to that man it was like one of our
biggest ones and
it was really rad we had it over at uh
the motor group
right over there at green street um
green street agency yeah great teenagers
yeah yeah
right before it's i mean obviously it
still hasn't i don't has it open yet
no they were building i talked to uh his
name i can't remember his name
uh super nice dude but yes the owner of
green street
yeah cool people there you have it over
there great people over there yeah
um like i said at the motor group which
is right next door i guess they had
offices next door anticipating you know
the new building to open and whatnot
so they they were [ __ ] graceful
enough to like lend us the the space for
the evening and
yeah it was really dope dude so omar
[ __ ] dj 8 it was dope
oh this is the last this is the two
years ago then yeah so what do you
expect in one of these poker because
that sounds scary as [ __ ] hey i'm
inviting all my friends they're all pro
skaters or are they actually this last
one was like
a mixture of everybody from like the you
know weed industry
from [ __ ] skate industry just all
walks of like just friends
it's been one of those grassroot things
it's like word of mouth that it's just
gotten to that point now i'm just like
damn we got
i got an actual [ __ ] poker tournament
here you know from like a house
tournament to like a full-blown like
yeah how many people
you think this last one was like at
least 50. damn yeah it was dope
you went are people winning money for
real yeah i mean it was definitely i
think
top ten got some money really yeah i
[ __ ] trash it up that sounds
sick yeah it was dope that's just a cool
experience man it's cool that i mean i'm
just stoked that people
you know were consistently coming for
the last [ __ ] 15 well it's 13 years
for them
it is right there yeah dude dan that's
the green street one that
no this was the one that was at a i
think this was a diamond i had oh you
had it
i had the diamond store for probably
like three years give or take
trophies and all yeah eleventh annual
damn you guys are
you made class trophies you guys are
serious
yeah it turned into something special
bro are you any good
i'm decent yeah i mean i've definitely
placed top ten
at least at least six seven times damn
yeah yeah i'll say do you win your own
trophy i haven't won i haven't won one
yet man
straight up no host bar [ __ ] it dude um
yeah and i wanted to bring that up
i saw it online like damn that must be a
[ __ ] that must be scary
how much money are you gonna walk into
that place with i mean to be honest it's
like the buy-in's only a hundred bucks
and then
you got a rebuy of a hundred bucks so
it's like yeah it's not too bad you know
okay i don't know i think i'm bringing
we people and approach
but then when they just when you when
people get uh you know um
they are out you know they have side
tables with cash games and whatnot too
there's a lot of other exciting things
going on so it's not like some vegas
seriousness where everybody's mad
no okay it's a it's a fun it's an
environmental friend you know poker
playing
listening to music smoking hanging
drinking yeah dude
sick yeah sick dude um
nice nice i wanted to i know it's
completely i'm about
i have a bunch of things in my head so
like you talked about earlier you're a
kid you're getting sponsorships you're
at school like yeah i'm sponsored doing
my [ __ ]
what was the first real brand that you
went home that day and go
yo mom i got [ __ ] sponsored by like
what was that first
spark of holy [ __ ] i might do something
with this
right um solomon again was a big part so
i'd say rios
being getting on real skateboards for a
brief moment yeah it was definitely
how old were you oh [ __ ] that was
probably like 14. yeah
yeah going turning getting ready to turn
15. yeah give or take
damn getting on the skate team yeah so
you were that kid where everybody's
looking yo he's a young ass boy hitting
rails
yeah man it was one of those things but
it was it's crazy because obviously um
real skateboards is based in in the bay
so it's insane yeah so um i would get up
to the bay every now and then and you
know obviously be able to visit but
it was one of those things where i kind
of like got sponsored you know
um there wasn't really anything formal
you know what i'm saying it was just
like you know he got some boards and
then next thing you know i had an ad
come
out for real yeah really yeah and then
um
[ __ ] it was so lame probably like i'd
say two weeks later i ended up quitting
because of the timing and the situation
of me meeting tim gavin and
him skating for blind and he basically
wanted me to skate for blind and
blind was a la-based company so and it
was blind
and you know obviously at the time [ __ ]
it was like tim gavin
uh guy mariano [ __ ] just just
legendary
[ __ ] people that make you want to be
better definitely
you know and to be a part of that group
i was just like dude let's go you know
what i mean
and i felt bad in hindsight obviously
quitting real
but timing it was in the morning yeah
you're in high school you to get to
frisco
yeah i mean look i can make excuses
about it but at the same time it was
just like
it was a perfect it was a perfect thing
for me to like kind of like
just jump into you know so what was it
like dude what was it like being on the
team what do you what was what can
somebody expect like
what do you do all day on the team what
are your
what are you guys doing that's it all
just skating all day yeah
escape and try to produce and get you
know film and
go to contest occasionally and you know
you take photos it's i mean it's it's
it's an ideal situation if you're just a
skateboarder you know what i mean
oh you're just making me so happy it's
super cool really as a kid that's all i
ever watched like
the closest thing we had besides skate
videos on tv was prank
it's remember [ __ ] whack ass brain
[ __ ] rollerbladers and [ __ ]
there was nothing sick on tv there was
no kind of anything until
one day [ __ ] tony hawk pro skater
came out and that was it
oh yeah and that's what that changed
every mainstream
person looking at skating that was
definitely opened the doors for
you know the skateboarding had arrived
dude like when the next games came out
mm-hmm do you remember
i remember like what 97 or six i feel
yeah maybe a little earlier yeah it
sounds about right but when that [ __ ]
came out i'm on tv like
you know for me i'm sitting here trash
at skateboarder i can only go fast
downhill i can't do tricks i'm a little
fat kid
but i love that [ __ ] i'm always hurt but
for me
watching basically all your peers
probably you
mm-hmm and all these skate because we
didn't have youtube right my friend had
skate videos yeah you ever seen this one
uh there was one
i can't remember the skater huge [ __ ]
hair but he cracked his [ __ ] head
open on like a 10 stare
and it went into like a cartoon they
didn't really show him all [ __ ] up
that's the first skate video i ever
watched in my life and i got hooked
amazing i got hooked those first skate
videos do it
yeah we watch the right one definitely
it can definitely change it's uh
it's like watching it's like watching a
podcast you start looking at these
people like friends you start getting to
know them a little more it's more it's
it's a little more in-depth and nobody
had ever really done that before for
sure so
what was the first video that you you
were featured in uh that i was featured
in
um [ __ ] it would have to be that when it
came out you're like get the [ __ ] out
here's me
uh the ftc video i think was probably
one of the first ones
but um goldfish i'd say between goldfish
and
in the ftc video but i think it was the
ftc video that i had
like a first like full part and that's
ftc is a skate shop in the bay um there
it is right there
um hey oh man you're a champion
[Music]
[ __ ] it's crazy to look back man how do
you
how does that make you feel man look at
you could do all of these things still
i'm just saying like look at you as a
child wow i wasn't
the guy that was jumping down [ __ ] i
occasionally jumped down stuff so
you know obviously i was more of a
surface to trying to stay on the ground
types
yeah break your back and [ __ ] um so some
of this stuff yeah i can still do this
[ __ ] but
yeah these are just the times man see
that just
that just reminds me of having fun as a
kid and watching that kid
because i'm like yo look at that kid's
good as [ __ ] and i'm just garbage
but i stay at the skate park watch
people that's crazy man crazy
bizarre but yeah you probably what 16
times yeah now this is little still like
15
16. really give or take yeah because i
was on
as [ __ ] is that blind right here so yeah
i'm like
it's crazy man that's sick yeah the
years get distorted too a little bit bro
as you're i mean once you get to a level
of like this is what i'm doing that's
what i'm doing this i'm doing
years ago buy fat super fast this kind
of scares me it really
i just turned 31 and i remember still
young
but i remember when i was 24 going i'm
gonna do this if it doesn't work out by
the time i'm like 28
i'll stop and 28 came by i was doing so
much i
forgot the years ago
oh that's right that's not me i'm a kid
i'm not a kid no more it's crazy i
forget
i trip on him man like i mean [ __ ] i
just turned 44. and i don't think
i don't feel 44 at it i used to look at
people when they're like
i'm like damn you know and now i'm just
like [ __ ] i'm in it like
and here we are you know but i don't
feel like that it's a whole different
thing
how do you feel i mean i don't feel 31 i
feel like i'm i just got out of high
school i thought you know what i
remember anything
exactly do you have any kids i do yeah i
have one kid he's uh
five and a half his name is legend
nice yeah [ __ ] uh lights up our world
bro real [ __ ]
oh no way he's gonna [ __ ] love that
about high school
janae don't even wanna know i know i
see what i thought about that too is he
going to get teased and [ __ ] no
he's going to talk he's going to live up
to his name you know i'm saying i'm not
saying that oh he's a legend by any
means i think
it's just the [ __ ] it's the name like
it's just a name
people right when i say that to people
like they're like damn that's [ __ ]
crazy
exactly yeah no he's five and a half
yeah
skating yet no man he's he likes stuff
to come easy to him
so it's like one of those things i'm
trying to present it to him and he's
just like
nah you know yeah not feeling it too
much you know and
the fact that he's i think i don't know
man it's i think
i don't want to push it on him you know
of course not that's one of those things
i'm just like i'll let him like i'm
gonna set up a board for him and like
i just presented but i'm not trying to
like you know kind of
you know force it yeah i'll try i'll
teach you
yeah one thing that i have been doing
i've been you know i'm i picked up
golfing like three
probably three years ago and he wants to
go to the driving range and you know i
got him a little set
so that's kind of dope i'm like kind of
seeing like you know he does want to try
certain things
certain things he's just like a little
timid intimidated by which is fine
yeah like you're saying he's wants you
to come easy skating's not [ __ ] easy
no dude but neither is golf so it's nice
but it's fun
yeah he's got himself set up here yeah
he can suck and still have fun at the
driving range that's damn strong
especially for kids
yeah nice so he's five and a half you
are you married i am
i got married to my high school
sweetheart so uh
[ __ ] we've been married for 13 years
and uh together for [ __ ] 27
years yeah 28 years going on it's crazy
wow yeah congratulations that's awesome
you guys are good
friends then oh yeah so that's the only
way it's going to work yeah dude
straight up i found it early man that's
one of those things i'm fortunate enough
to be able to
you know because at the end of the day i
know how rare this [ __ ] is like
people don't stay in relationships like
that yeah dude when i was uh
she was 15 i was 17. well you know
exactly what class you met her and where
did you meet her at
uh spanish class there you go i knew you
would remember yeah she's your best
friend like i remember where she walked
in i said hello
oh yeah definitely no [ __ ] that's super
rad man that's [ __ ] cool man that's
that's awesome and i'm a loyal ass dude
too so it's one of those things but
you know even with friends like i'm just
you know it's one of those things like i
have long time friends as well you know
30 yeah my one of my best friends i've
known from since i was like
10 years old so 34 years man wow yeah
that's a trip man that's so sick high
school same girl that's great
yeah how cool and good thing good for
you guys waiting to have a ch have a kid
yeah i mean it was one if we had issues
you know it wasn't like uh you know a
lot of people could just you know
boom and this happens you got you us we
had the you know
we we did uh in vitro we had to take the
the right
yeah how was that it was uh it was
different you know obviously
um but all in all i mean if we have a
beautiful little boy that you know
you know we had we had to spend a little
bit of money but that's it comes with
the territory with the
you know ivf so um it was a cool
experience definitely like i said it
wasn't your
you know your normal your natural way to
do it but nothing wrong with that
at least we had options you know what
i'm saying so how cool i'm very thankful
that you know
that that option was there you know were
you guys trying for a long time do you
realize you have to try and vitro
definitely you know and one of those
things it's like you know i had to stop
smoking i had to stop drinking there was
a lot of things that i had to do
oh to see what it was yeah because you
know you had to go do you know your test
and you know see
what you're doing down you know and see
how that's working you know
and yeah i had to i had to be discipline
myself and do some things that you know
i had to
change my lifestyle a little bit you
know and it was for that brief moment
but you know
after everything was said and done you
know we you know we were able to do
whatever we wanted to again after that
but
you know he's here now so it's all good
you know he's thinking about any more
kids or not
i would love to you know um like i said
time is of the the essence in the sense
of
we don't have that much time so if we
are we're gonna do we have to do it now
you know um that's something you're
thinking about
yeah we've been thinking about it it's
just like we gotta either do it or just
[ __ ]
hang it up and figure it out oh [ __ ]
this is the one this is the episode man
no i mean we've been this is like
something we've been talking about you
know
um whether we're gonna make the [ __ ]
official like we're doing it now like no
that's not the case i think like i said
if we're gonna do it we
we definitely have to figure it out here
in the next i'm like saying like six
months type [ __ ]
yeah well another life-changing thing
they have to have i know
really if we decide that way you know we
take that step you know
wow man that's that's awesome i've been
with my girlfriend well
fiance now we got engaged last week
actually we've been here really
yeah since we've been 22. there you go
so you're in this year you're on your
way too you're gonna be right here
exactly that's when i hear like yeah
[ __ ] you yeah nine years is no joke bro
i mean
straight up yeah you're on your way
that's so sick to hear man you're all
hyped when you said it too that's
[ __ ] awesome i feel people look at me
like for real like
you don't feel that way yeah dude i mean
yeah i'm truly blessed
and you know thankful for for my wife
that's for sure
awesome man six so legends five and a
half likes golfing
might my dad won't skating we'll see
that's sick dude
yeah dude i shouldn't be smoking during
the stereo ads
right okay
i just thought about it right now like
wait should i light the rest of this joy
no i sure did here we go ready you let
me know
okay i got it what's up guys thank you
oh [ __ ] this is mid roll
mid roll what's up guys yes oh sh
train good good timing [ __ ]
here we go ready what's up guys
this is another mid roll at oh [ __ ] you
what's up guys thank you again for being
part of the podcast thank you so much
for supporting and if you're here right
now don't forget to drop a like on the
video
guys let's get right into this thank you
so much again we are finally
like normal podcast people we have a
sponsor and our first sponsor thank you
so much for them for working with us
this is the stereo app for everyone out
there that does not know what this is
this is basically
a live chat for us this is for the
podcast this is for
maybe two to three times a week we go
live if you want to be part of the
of the conversation you can join in if
you want to just listen
basically like another extension of the
podcast said we're talking
q a maybe it's marty and i talking maybe
it's just
him giving tips on how to edit maybe
it's
me telling you how to grow your youtube
whatever it is it's gonna be for us it's
not
it's not like another platform you see
what i'm saying this is more for us this
is for
the fans this is more intimate talking
this is stereo app so do me a favor
right now
click the link in the description no
matter if you're listening to spotify
um apple if you're watching on youtube
the link in the description for the
stereo app
is our direct link if you click that
you're really helping us out guys
click that follow uh follow us as dope
as usual
download the app that's gonna really
help us out i'm being completely
transparent like i said
this is us guys um the more you guys
follow the more
we can do more the more the more we get
[ __ ] paid so all right so help us out
help us get help us make the podcast
bigger help
me and marty alleviate some of these
[ __ ] stresses i appreciate you
guys
but yeah like i said this is more
intimate talking this is just for us
stereo app
click the link in our description thank
you guys so much for listening to me
rant
i appreciate it have a dope ass day back
to the episode
i gotta remember not to say [ __ ] during
their ad read
um my next question
um as as in the 90s
early 2000s the decks that's all i can
get
we that's all we can get we didn't have
a zoomies or we had a pacsun i think it
was
right that's where you can buy decks at
right i've seen you have a
shitload of decks yeah that's like you
know me
just collecting that's nope that's
that's your baseball card man
yeah that's a skating baseball car like
yeah you got the deck yeah i got the
original and the plastic
yeah what was your first one if you can
remember like
i know you've had so many but my first
uh the first product or my first
like first board that i've ever got
typed no the first
pro oh you know what no no what's the
first deck you ever got
for yourself exactly i had a somebody
give me a
steve rocco like mini freestyle board
that was kind of like one of my first
boards that i had that
it wasn't brand new but someone gave it
to me but i remember it was just like a
steve rocco mini because i was a small
kid
you know at 10 years old i was [ __ ]
little you know so a
freestyle board was actually appropriate
at the time which is like you know
they're
like a banana thinner you know thinner
board and you know not like a banana
board not a banana board no
it was more like a freestyle board
remember you remember
there was no there was curves on it yeah
yeah it's a little i don't think i've
ever seen one before yeah really
or maybe i'm not marty can you bring
that up freestyle skateboard
like a freestyle board it's like a oh
those circle ones
the smaller thinner boards what boards
these days are like you know people like
skating eight and a half at that time
they were probably like
[ __ ] like six and a half six and a
half
inches wide so they're like super small
yo you just schooled the [ __ ] out of me
right now i don't
i've never seen one of these [ __ ]
boards in my life that's funny
what yeah oh those ones sorry marty i
thought you were talking about those
ones those are like long boards
i'm dumb i was looking at the wrong oh
look at the wrong [ __ ] picture
um so what was your first pro deck girl
skateboards
so girl turn me pro uh in 97.
oh [ __ ] um was it 97 to 99
96 excuse me and um yeah man it was like
a year after i'd
uh graduated high school and um i
i think i did my first my first pro
contest with the uh
slam city jams in vancouver so that was
kind of like the coming out
slow party right out of high school went
to your if did you get flown you had to
like
yeah we got flown out there yeah yeah
definitely no i mean they skateboarding
got me all over the world bro i'm really
like
blessed from that standpoint i have
literally been everywhere
for skateboard contests just no not
contests just in general like oh just to
go skate
yeah like for demos and just traveling
in general yeah
i'm sorry my bad guys
that was the loudest sound on earth
sorry i scared i thought someone kicked
our door in right now i'm scared the
[ __ ] at me my bad i looked over
concerned and [ __ ]
um so you've been everywhere to skate so
if you're saying your first contest was
you said slam city jam
yeah that's like there was a it was a
contest they had in uh vancouver canada
every well they probably had i'd like to
say three years
it was very short-lived so for these
contests you walk
for everyone out there doesn't know this
is a street
contest or flag yeah street contest they
would have obstacles and stuff yeah
right so
for everyone out there that probably not
familiar with skateboarding you've seen
this before it's like a fake park
and you go out there you have what two
minutes three minutes a minute a minute
yeah oh [ __ ] that was way longer now
yeah damn a minute how was the first one
have you ever been in a contest like no
i've been i've been in contests
but i was an amateur the pros like i was
definitely like in my head thinking
about it a little bit too much
um but yeah you got to go out there and
put it together for a minute and
you know i landed a couple things and
probably bailed the rest so
you know and that minute goes by really
fast as you know so
um yeah but all in all it was it was a
fun first experience for my
first pro contest wow man that's just so
sick you go out there you get in the
hotel
yeah oh my god that's just they have
parties and stuff
too it's pretty dope like and at that
time i think
[ __ ] i think it's at 19 years old to get
into like you know bars and [ __ ] out
there at that time oh in canada yeah
yeah
oh it's not 21 or anything nice so
yeah it's 18 it could be 18. it's
probably a teammate
yeah it seems like it's the [ __ ] yes
vancouver is [ __ ] sick as [ __ ]
beautiful beautiful city skated over
there yeah
beautiful city like all in all just yeah
really great people
dope city it's like one of those ones
like i would probably live there i could
i would live in vancouver for sure
vancouver canada i mean i lived in
portland so i it's kind of close i guess
it's not too far not too far but
everyone does seem nicer when you the
the less hot it gets everyone just gets
nicer i feel like i've had some funny
funny [ __ ] happen out there man i was
like at like a 7-11 randomly right down
the street from our hotel and i was
picking up some likes whatever
some snacks and [ __ ] and [ __ ] um i
checked i
checked my and i didn't i forgot my
wallet and i'm like damn i've come
can you hold this stuff here i'll be
right back and the dude behind me was
like no
don't worry about it i'll pay for it i
was like huh
it was probably like ten dollars for the
[ __ ] damn but like
just in 1996 ten dollars it was 22
i just thought it was really a [ __ ]
amazing thing for this dude that didn't
know me did that
hey i'll pay for don't worry about it
like okay that's how you guys do it out
here
you know what i mean i don't know all
canadians are nice i mean i had great
experiences out there so
yeah so vancouver so the guy just paying
for your [ __ ] yeah
first time being was that when you were
there yeah it was my first time out
there and first time you know
in that city and just like i said it was
just a random like
thoughtful thing to do i guess for
somebody you know what i mean i don't
know yeah
yeah that's cool man yeah super cool
that [ __ ] never happened before that's
why i'm like damn
they're pretty tight out there that
happened to me i was about
eight years old and i used to go buy wwf
wrestlers at the store on my team those
big ones
uh no they were like the seven inch ones
they were like harder rubber yep the wwf
guys
and it was buy one get one free and i
was like 60 cents short and i remember i
look at the cashier i'm like seven years
old like yo you
[ __ ] and this lady behind me is
like no don't worry and i never looked
like thank you thinking people help
people
i never had nobody help me ever before
no one offered to give me [ __ ] totally
this lady ran and that's what like
opened my head like maybe there are nice
[ __ ] out here
there is i don't know we are that's
that's the first time that ever happened
to me and like
sparked a little man that feeling yeah i
remember i mean
like i said it's one of those things
that's a highlight that stood out for me
especially
yeah all these years later and it
happened to be in vancouver you know
what i'm saying so
yeah nice man
so i wanted to ask you i everybody then
that's noticed all right i mean for
everyone that's not high as [ __ ] and
haven't noticed
the nine club on your sweater yeah the
podcast you're part of yup can you tell
us a little about that i watched
two episodes the other day it's very
informational like i feel like i was
learning some [ __ ] right off the bat
it's it's not just banter i feel
maybe because you guys aren't [ __ ] up
but right i feel like you guys are on
your [ __ ] well then again it is your
field but
i feel like i was learning more than i
was just sitting there watching skate
videos and [ __ ]
right so how did you get it come about
that i knew you told me earlier that you
came a little late
into the start right right so um chris
roberts and roger bagley
uh created this this platform called the
nine club
um say that close to five years ago if
not over five years ago
um basically they just interview
skateboarders
initially when it started off they just
come and you would interview you know
any of your favorite pro skateboarders
um and then they evolved into a weekly
show called the experience
where it's like um we just talk about
what's happening on a weekly basis in
the skateboard industry
so you know obviously people putting out
video parts and you know
it could be nike releasing a shoe
anything
like that revolves in skateboarding so
the podcast is is essentially a
skateboard podcast but we don't want to
be subjected to just skateboarding
yeah so you know culture it's basically
a culture yeah
uh podcast for the most part nice but
you know
it's it's i've been on since august um
i first initially going on i went on as
a guest
so i've been honest that's how it
started yeah but these are my friends
i've
like i said i've chopped girl and
chocolate
skateboards um are obviously like family
if you don't know
and now you know um but chris and justin
which are
two of the people that are on the the
nine club
um are on chocolate so i've traveled
these guys i've you know
they're like i said close friends of
mine um so i made it a little easier for
me to kind of
you know naturally i guess be a part of
the podcast so to say
talking with your friends yeah so it
makes it easier to you know i never
envisioned myself being on a podcast by
any means but in this
in this way in fashion it's [ __ ] easy
you know
it's what you know it yeah have you ever
done anything like that before where
you're on camera talking
i mean i've been in other you know i've
had other interviews where yeah
well i mean interviews are one have you
ever had to be on something to where you
have to continuously talk like that
because i know it's so
no this is the first time no this is the
first time that was the first time
initially and now that i'm in it it's
yeah it was a little different but like
i said i think it made it easier
because i was so comfortable with them
yeah of course
if it was me just coming into an arena
where i was just like
a new guy and i didn't know any of these
people it would have been a little
different for sure
like into a new school yeah for sure you
definitely wouldn't
yeah it would have took a little
adjusting not that i wasn't adjusting
while it's happening but you know it
definitely made it a lot easier
who are some of the guests you've had on
there besides i mean you do all pro
skills so right now
there's a basically obviously since the
pandemic they had to kind of pivot
and do they couldn't do the in-person
thing so they did uh
they formulated another show called stop
and chat
so the stop and chat is kind of a format
based on
previous guests so guests that have
already been on they come on again
and they do it via zoom and it's just
like a catch-up from when they were on
previous previously um so that's kind of
been working in this you know obviously
in the state that we're in right now i
think
to where we're going to get back is you
know i don't know what
what date that's going to be it's kind
of hard to be like all right this is
date
because i think chris and roger they
don't want to have any um
any downplay or any any hiccups in the
sense of like if they're going to be
starting again it's going to be
on a weekly basis again so as far as
like trying to
recruit guests they don't want to have
any hiccups they want to make
sure that if we are moving forward then
we're going to have guests
stay consistently ready you know yeah so
um
as of right now there's no you know no
no
date dialed in because of just the state
we're in um but it's going to be sooner
and later i would i would imagine so
because it seems like things are
starting to
pick back up people are going to get
there there's people around that side
i know it's just crazy psycho bro it
really is so wild to seeing mass
everywhere still i mean i'm not
comfortable with it i don't think i ever
it makes me feel off
it does like i mean i'll wear it when i
need to wear it you know out and out and
about and stuff but
did i feel some way some some way about
it if i'm like taking my son on a bike
ride in my neighborhood and some [ __ ]
like i'm not trying to wear a mask
it's so if i see somebody coming alright
i'll throw it on real quick but yeah if
there's anybody around me i have to have
it on just because
maybe something out of my clothes and
you're susceptible to being sick and i
get you sick as [ __ ] i'm gonna feel
terrible
totally i mean it's just just being
courteous at this point
yeah that's all it is at this point get
away from me i'll get away from you it
sucks
no it's it's yeah it's not the way to
live that's for sure it's so different
man
it's so different but uh your kid would
have been in your
legend would just started what
kindergarten uh he will start
kindergarten next year so right now he's
like in the
in transition the transitional yeah
where we kind of took a year
because fortunate enough that you know i
say fortunate
the unfortunate situation that we're in
um
he was able to get into a pod with three
other kids
and like kind of like a guest house at
somebody's house and they have an actual
teacher
so he's actually getting you know you
know a really school
school education in a sense without the
whole zoom thing i mean the whole zoom
thing is so
bizarre to me but it is what it is pod
means classroom yes
sorry i didn't explain that about that
just just in case i was a little
yeah a pot is a little like a little
classroom pretty much yeah
wow yeah crazy in the 1800s
yeah holy [ __ ] it was so crazy bro i
mean
but fortunate enough he's able to you
know at least have that for now because
he was just at how if at home and like
just on zoom like and not really able to
engage with other kids it's just
it's not this sucks for kids man right
now honestly i think about it now but
kids these days have no idea now i have
no idea what it'd be like
to not be able to do my senior year
because i'm stuck at home on
oh that sucks for like i feel for people
graduating high school or graduating
college and [ __ ]
like anything just missing out or yours
your son's gonna what
start kindergarten actually knowing
there's four kids in class that's a
whole different world well he's gonna
probably go to
uh public school next year so i'm sure
that they're gonna figure it out but i
know it's not gonna be no
four kids they'll probably be 12 kids
you know what i'm saying
or you know i don't know what we'll see
we'll see what it is yeah we have to see
that's wild though yeah i couldn't i
couldn't imagine man i don't
i don't know if i could do this one
that's crazy bro i don't think i could
it really is i would be sneaking the
[ __ ] out of my house
i'd be doing something i would
definitely be missing class while being
at home
there's no doubt i couldn't do it um
i have a question for you just off the
top of your head yep
say it's 1993 right now we're in la
where where's the best skate spots uh 93
[ __ ] i'll probably be either at the la
court house
um or downtown or los feliz there's la
felix
uh elementary or lockwood
these are both like right away legendary
spots
you know really yeah see i'm not from
i'm from up north but yeah it'll be the
santa monica courthouse
los feliz elementary which is in los
feliz um and then lockwood which is in
and it's in a [ __ ] cuts you got to
like you know you got to be
got to be careful you got to be careful
going to lock wood yeah
really yeah some gaming [ __ ] yep damn
sounds like merced
that sucks but now but you know the
gangsters would
they would let the skaters do their
thing it's different now
out there he's getting it there he is
damn martin you already brought it up
i love it bro that's the back end of it
but lockwood
absolutely there it is right there yeah
that's the the little pla
because there's banks there and [ __ ]
they're used yeah they're still there
they're still there
amazing bro the technology man i know he
just brought it up
i love it that's so dope yeah these are
legendary spots and yeah around that
time 93.
so i got a question for you have you
seen that movie the mid 90s
yes
it yes good i got to give it to him and
he did a really good job with it you
know
um i think this new movie that's coming
out uh that illegal sieve just did
that um they're depicting kind of how it
is to become a skateboarder and i'm
really anticipating
to see it as well i'm having a space
moment i can't remember the name of the
[ __ ] movie at the moment
it's it's coming out soon it's coming
out soon um
[ __ ] god damn why am i having a [ __ ]
illegal civilization why am i not
[ __ ]
thinking yeah dude there's like some
really heavy hitters and like vince
vaughn's in it
what there it is boom it's going to be a
really
i like i said it's called north
hollywood there it is north hollywood
so i think yeah watch out for this is
going to be you know i think it's going
to be really authentic to what
to how it is to become a pro skater
it's um no [ __ ] yeah dude well yeah
that's why i brought up the mid 90s just
because i thought
yo this little kid's me that little boy
i'm like yeah that was me
hey i was just hung out with such older
people totally started getting [ __ ] up
i don't know i just same [ __ ] i think i
caught
loved it yeah now mid 90s was a really
good movie but uh like i said i'm
looking forward to seeing the north
hollywood movies i
said straight to it it was a netflix
movie right netflix is the new
theaters man that's ridiculous i know
dude it's like going right to like
prime or [ __ ] it's clear right yeah
yeah make it dark in here
man all right we're at the movie theater
that's the new going out man
it's [ __ ] weird maybe they're having
like the drive-in theaters now too that
i've seen
pop-up yeah i do too that's free that
brings back that old like
that's very cool you can smoke weed in
your car straight
and then you can smoke weed yep
new [ __ ] nice man
north hollywood movie but it was like i
can't deny it mid 90s was a really good
movie and it definitely
you know it was authentic to a degree
yeah for me growing up just as a little
kid trying to skate still getting [ __ ]
up that i
i was just i loved it relatable i loved
it so much
um i have a clip i wanted to show you
real quick marty
can you bring up that first clip yeah
yeah i got this clip i want to show you
what's your opinion on this i think it's
a mint uh what is it second 26 ah this
dude's gnarly
watch this look at this right here look
at this
little [ __ ] guy yeah that's that's
what's that jaws [ __ ] i have no idea
yeah this [ __ ] yeah i mean there's
that's some stunt man [ __ ] you know
that's stuntman [ __ ] it literally
stopped [ __ ] we just we just
actually did a stopping chat with josh
so that's with that skater right there
this dude right here yeah
he's gnarly that's what he does you know
i mean we're all 20 that's like what 20
plus stairs
yeah that's [ __ ] up [ __ ] that's just
insane
but that's what he does it's so rad
because like there's so many different
types of skateboarders you know
and he happens to be like that guy you
know he jumps down [ __ ] and
you know i can't i have a homie like
that but i'm not willing to yeah
right he flew out there specifically to
do that
to that spot you know up to that video
yeah where is this at
that is in europe i forget exactly where
but yeah he
it's a full-blown mission
oh my god yeah this was insane
skaters put it on the line yeah that's i
mean that's no joke bro that's just like
have you seen anything bigger than that
i'm sure you have seen it all
i mean this is one of the biggest things
for sure yeah yeah
you you picked it good [ __ ]
this is i don't think i've ever seen
something bigger than that that's
definitely one of them
that's unbelievable did even let did he
land it eventually he did
he went he had to go back he went back
again and did it oh gosh
i think he got hurt right there oh when
he's the damn splits
yeah wanted to bring this up look at
this thing is it jackass oh yeah
i don't even know they made the biggest
skateboard i mean well i don't think
it's jackass look they
whoever these people are with the with
like the actual pieces yeah yeah yeah
they they made the world's biggest
skateboard that's amazing
you can turn and hit though oh
was it them was it rob that did it i
thought he did that [ __ ]
is it him i don't know but that [ __ ] was
unreal
i just saw it the other day and thought
it was unbelievable look at that yeah
you could skate off of it that's insane
hey you need a giant to skate that thing
that was tight as [ __ ]
um the first time i was ever shocked was
the rodney mullen video
right uh the compilation was at this
back of the school
remember that what's the name i don't
remember it's the rodney mullen
um it's the first time i ever saw a dark
slide
huh it was probably a plan b video i
can't remember i just remember watching
it just
well like i said as a kid and i sucked
looking at all this [ __ ]
so sick oh this is the old-school one
he's like yeah
where is this at oceanside 1980 that is
six
this is when i like was like you know
like
i think it's 8687 because i i definitely
was
somewhat paying attention to a degree
too
i think in 87 valsurf had like a
crazy um back to back where they had
in the summertime they had like alva
come through and powell
like and all these crazy demos i
remember going and and checking it out
yeah i went to the oh no yeah and
checking oh [ __ ]
yeah wow man that's this is buff this is
pre-skate videos this is pretty
everything
they have videos it's very selective
like you can i remember you could like
rent videos at like your your local
video shop you know
really yeah my friends just had them i
never knew you could like search for
animal chin
and holiday havoc they're like you know
they were um
i've never even heard of them yes these
are like steak contest videos and stuff
which is about animal habits
search for animal chin it was like a pal
video you never heard of that no
wow no let me see this the search for
animal chin
yeah that's a pal
that's just a legendary old skateboard
video that you know
oh wow it's legendary it's tony hawk
lance mountain
everybody that was on pile at that time
tommy guerrero mike mcgill
yeah this is uh this is old i love it
i had a big fat board it was a pink
panther one and it had the damn
i was like six and it had the plastic
grind rails
with those skateboard rails yeah that
[ __ ] was sick
i was like six or seven and i had that i
love it wow yeah
boards just like that the fat ones yeah
damn i remember rob deerdack was going
to make like a street league
to try to make like a league out of
skateboarding oh he did he did what
happened yeah he did he's treated
him [ __ ] phenomenal job with it it's
uh [ __ ]
[ __ ] it was around for like at least
it's still around to be honest they're
they're still doing it what does that
mean
so it's basically it's uh it's a
skateboard league so it's a contest
essentially
um but it's uh you get scored on points
throughout the year and you know whoever
scores the most points
in all these contests that they have
throughout the year you know you oh
for just that like some nfl [ __ ] yeah
exactly
what that is sick as well it's all
individuals though you have to be on a
team
uh no no you don't have to be on a team
it's it's it's an individual sport as
you know
yeah um but you know you have to qualify
they had probably have qualifying for
you know certain people that weren't
already kind of um
um brandon biebel yeah there's so many
[ __ ] skaters in it
wow oh [ __ ] no i don't know this
it's official bro i definitely diamond
sponsored a best trick contest there it
was a yeah it was a
it had a moment man it was definitely i
think it was probably had a good
six years seven years that it was really
doing some some special things man
the first time i ever went to agenda you
guys are doing the best trick contest
outside oh yeah yeah that was awesome i
never i've never seen
a con i've never seen a contest it's a
merced right i've never seen nothing
sick but i never seen a
skateboard contest before it was [ __ ]
awesome oh you just saw that recently
that was probably five years ago that
was sick
it was tight though yeah that [ __ ] was
awesome i've never seen it before like
in person mm-hmm um
nice dude omar sent me that link i had
to bring that [ __ ] up
[ __ ] that's omar's doing right there
yeah what is this right here girl scape
work though that's what that was when i
was amateur that was like kind of right
before i turned pro it was just doing
like a funny ad in a sense of you know
working am program so i like made it
seem like i was working and then you
know obviously out skating at the same
time
yeah how old are you 14 15 again yeah
it's like
15 probably yo 16. see that shit's
sick was that in the magazine yeah
that's tight yeah
it's crazy that's cool um i
have one more clip to show you yeah i
wanted to bring up
you got it marty i think it's the last
one this [ __ ] is hard as [ __ ]
let me answer that i know it's weird
probably this is the pretty sweet part
yeah this shit's hard as hell i know
she's like yeah i'm watching myself but
i just had to show up
for everybody at home i just wanted to
show this it's so
[ __ ] tight i know yeah there's a part
i shared with uh brandon biebel
i watched this twice last night it's so
[ __ ] cool yeah man it's just
watching people do stuff you would love
to do but just can't
it's like watching [ __ ] nfl like
watching basketball
same [ __ ] yeah and i'm a big fan of
basketball like i said golf any of that
stuff
i admire anybody that's really talented
in their craft
you know what i'm saying so it could be
anything that you do
dvs did you you were you were on the uh
sponsor yesterday by dvs from the
beginning you know
from the very beginning dvs started in
95 that was on in the beginning and
really yeah and then um [ __ ] i think
around
shoes 2008 was like yeah the end of
me being well 2009.
really yeah damn yeah but dvds was red
definitely
great times skating for them i remember
world industries
yeah oh [ __ ] yeah dude i remember that
the little fire i had those shirts i
used to get made fun of because i'm in
the [ __ ] ghetto
flame boy yeah i used to get made fun of
all the skate gear i used to have i used
to have like
um america's [ __ ] and people make fun of
me because i'm from
you know the [ __ ] ghetto fat little
mexican kid like
what is that [ __ ] you don't even speak
spanish you're a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yo it's that [ __ ] sucks
adolescent days i know bro going through
those moments of yeah
it was just a skate [ __ ] too because i
loved it and my homies are like the only
other white kids another mexican kid
that skated
it's a small town totally and i got it
all how far is that from here
it's like four and a half hours on that
train that's
my four and a half hours hear that thing
well dude oh man thank you so much
yeah dude this is fun bro thank you so
much you got a good little thing going
on over here bro
it's been cool man i'm uh i'm excited
for everything everything's going well
we're just getting it going like i said
you i'm i'm new to this
yeah you're just like you're saying you
are like i just got in in august
it's a difference it's different it's
super different bro
i'm trying to just like you know just be
in the moment with it the end of the day
you know
it's a it's an opportunity that was
presented to me and i'm just like let's
go you know and just have fun with it
you know it's been uh
like i said unexpected that i would like
it so much and like you know want to
engage and really be down and to talk
into the cameras and [ __ ] it's just like
i didn't think i would be comfortable
with it but like yeah it's it's it's
turned into something that i'm
you know i'm happy to be doing at the
moment and you're like oh i think i can
get better doing this
yeah i did i think with time for sure
yeah you know
with anything you know exactly it's a
whole new it's a
i didn't think it'd be like another
craft almost it is
it's talking to your friends it's cool
it's fine talking on camera with a
conversation is a completely different
story it is
definitely right but as far as being the
like the the narrator and the monitor i
think that's that's harder
like so you're someone in your position
and someone in like chris's position
that's
um the nine club it's like that's a
talent
i really think to kind of keep the the
momentum of an interview going and like
that
you know where there's no dull moments
so to say that [ __ ] is hard
so hard yeah it's another job it's
[ __ ] cool i gotta i gotta think i
can't just say
yeah you know what i'm talking about
yeah it's like a flowy thing that just
you know
sometimes you really don't you set up
the guests and then they just kind of
take it on its own you kind of you know
work it around the guest
so whatever they're talking about then
you could kind of formulate to and kind
of go on a tangent
so you could there's ways that i'm
starting to see like damn okay that's
how it works a little bit it makes it
you know kind of flawless yeah dude
because you know
it can it can turn into like a [ __ ]
stale moment easy
you know i know what you feel strange of
course i do that [ __ ] by myself like i
said
i cut all my videos up sometimes i'll do
that to myself just space out
oh yeah that's what i was talking about
yeah imagine doing that [ __ ] on camera
with people that [ __ ] was terrible yeah
and then you try to go into the live
format like
hell you better be seasoned bro season
yeah that's just hard man but it really
is with time like you said you're doing
it's the first time you've ever done
like
long-form interviews and this and you
have your friends just more comfortable
it's
and i'm not leading it that's why it
makes it easier i'm like kind of just
like the co-host
which is fine for me like if i'm
stepping into this i definitely want i
don't want to be
like the guy you know i'm saying i'd
rather be the co-host so i can't see
he can lean on me to a degree you know
what i mean so yeah it's been like i
said it's been great man
i'm having fun with it sick dude um
before i go i want to show you
i mean i want to show everybody at home
i was just looking at this last night
yeah this [ __ ] just got released today
on did it really
yeah yeah i mean it's it's been out it's
been released internationally for a
while
for the past like three weeks but
domestically
and now the crail store you can go to
crailstore.com
which is a girl and chocolate uh
website and oh no you can purchase that
right in the description yeah put this
link in there
shit's hard as [ __ ] when i was in the
10th grade i had a girl sticker on my
binder i mean i didn't [ __ ] do
anything at school
i had it on my binder i just remember
people like why do you have a picture of
a girl like
you just don't know what's going on with
my homies girls chocolate shirts
and [ __ ] yeah so hearing you i always
get questions about that like what is
that
like why do you wear them it's a board
company company man yeah
not the bathroom [ __ ] it's a company
it's like
it's back before like i said back
forward people were like yo skating sick
like no you skate you probably smoke
weed at the park and [ __ ]
you probably were but you're still
skating totally you know what i mean
totally it's back before people like nah
that shit's tight as [ __ ] x games yeah
you know tony hawk robbed your dick made
that [ __ ] so [ __ ]
they really i mean they put it on the
map man robbed the urduc as well man big
ups to him man he's definitely
a trailblazer man also before we leave
i wanted to ask you about one more thing
yeah a different realm different
something else you're doing blonde
yeah so it's a cannabis company yeah uh
so funny you bring that up okay so about
a year and a half ago
you know me and a few other uh of my
entrepreneurial friends we wanted to you
know start a company
and we we came up with it and we had
some partners in vegas
and um the partners in vegas
who were working under this this
conglomerate they got fired
and they were partners of ours and they
are basically the back end of the brand
of your brand yeah so
after they got fired we pretty much were
like kind of dead in the dirt
so now we are we're currently we're
trying to find a back end
really so yeah right now it's uh where
it's so
back end you mean the logistics of the
company
basically i like that i can help you
actually with that
very easily that would be amazing
exactly who to talk to that would be
amazing so you already have this
pre-existing company that you
how did you curate this yeah me and a
few but well my buddy uh chris keith
he is him and his wife are [ __ ] so
talented man and they they came up with
the name and the whole concept
look ooh the vibe i like that right it's
got a really really really great
aesthetic man and
i'd hate for it to go to waste that's
for sure because i think that it has a
really
it has a great vibe behind it that's
your co-owner code
owner co-owner yeah i mean it's our
brand at the moment but like i said if
we don't have no back end there's no
brand
and what we wanted to do was kind of be
like have a play like um
i wouldn't i'm not trying to say like a
cookies play by any means but we we're
going to have an apparel
tied to it but the apparel that it's
going to be more high elevated
apparel you know it's not going to be
like what you're wearing right there
this is not real this is not like that
the stuff that that that
we were doing with blonde is a little
bit more elevated the pieces were like
you could tell so the word it's like a
really beautiful piece it's not like
just something that you can just
you know print up yeah so like you
talking about one-offs or just
high-quality high-fashion
streetwear kind of but not really you
know
trying to stay in our lane so to say you
know we're not trying to go beyond
you know but like i said it was really
cool aesthetic really playing pieces
that but the the materials are really
great it's not like you know you like i
said you can't just go pick this up at
[ __ ]
you know no totally
yeah we wanted to try to elevate it a
little bit because it's i think there's
room
you know and there's so much room in in
in the in the
in the marijuana industry so to say like
because there's so many different types
of brands and
you know if you know what there's room
where you're going there's room for
anything there's any level and form you
can think of all of it there's room
for sure a hundred percent yeah so
you're co-owner to that
yeah so now that the the the uh backing
the back end got pulled we we own the
obviously we own the brand 100 so you're
just so we're kind of just sitting on it
i'm meeting with people i mean i've i've
met with my good friends over at maven
you know i mean i have really people
like some good people in the industry
that you know i'm kind of leaning on but
like
to be honest like i i don't really have
that much money to put into this
more much more money to put into this so
i definitely want to kind of lean on
somebody that has
some [ __ ] like already hooked up ready
and just kind of we kind of just plug in
type [ __ ]
gotcha yeah yeah yeah so you take over
but you just
not taking over i mean you use your
resources exactly
and you take over what you need to do
with their resources
totally and we'll like let's say we will
do the front end of like as far as
marketing and getting it out there like
that's that's what you're going to do
stuff yeah that's easier
versus you know you know yeah that that
back-end portion is just it's
it's important we need a grower it's no
you need a facility
a team exactly who exactly and you know
we're willing to give you know
give up something for that you know
you're in the
ah man for just to get pulled like that
that's a
so oh it shook i mean that's the thing
we're like we're here we are thinking
we're about to launch last 4 20
and you know this is last year this is
last year yeah and with that pandemic
and that [ __ ] [ __ ] up meetings even
more so you know
so yeah i think it was just bad timing
bro really
you know but we had good momentum
because you know we already launched in
vegas we were trying to launch in in
california that's where because they
were in
they were in motion to do so you know so
it just
like i said man it was uh in time
smoking mirrors sometimes bro but in
time yes i'm patient bro i don't
gotta rush things don't happen overnight
and i'm very aware industry is new
yeah even though it's been years it's
brand new because it's just started
it it's gonna get times uh people don't
even understand it seems like it's
oversaturated to a degree but it's but
people understand how big it's going to
get
another state opens up and that state
opens and that oh and then it's
federalism and then it's like
yeah game of thrones it's federal it's
like selling different soda brands
now at this point no doubt there's
trillions of dollars at this point yeah
man i mean there's room for everybody
like you said
yeah like i said and we have a different
type of niche like i don't i haven't
seen anything that looks like us
okay that was sick you know i love if
you look at the instagram you kind of
get an idea of like you know
it's not it's not what i see i mean i
see a lot of other brands that are
definitely this different
you know that that kind of they're
following what's cool
or what what what seems to be working
right that's i'm not mad at that
that's that's dope i think you should if
you if you feel
you know confident about your company
like that run that way but i think you
know
for us it's a little more like cleaner
aesthetic and you know
definitely a good product at the end of
the day it's just like the clothing
industry if you
you can ride trends but every trend
[ __ ] falls so if you're just writing
every trend you're just gonna fall off
each time yeah
same thing with the same thing with this
man for sure that's
i like that that's sick that means a lot
coming from you bro
real [ __ ] nice
yeah maybe we'll talk after we'll see
you oh no no
don't worry i just want to say i got you
don't worry um
well i want to say thank you so much for
coming on here dude thanks for choosing
having me bro
real [ __ ] thanks for the board yes dude
for real thank you and also
since you're a bond guy there's a
you pick take your pick yeah all right
thank you
a lot of them flowing out of you bro
whatever you want that's so awesome bro
i appreciate it bro definitely yeah
thank you so much i want to appreciate
i want to say thank you so much for
coming out here mm-hmm let's get you out
of here
whoo thank you guys congratulations to
everything going on bro i'm stoked for
you bro appreciate it thank you podcast
is just the beginning man i think you
got a lot going on
thank you thanks for coming on friends
uh nine the nine club
yeah definitely for everybody out there
links in the description
will uh definitely be watching it thank
you so much
i think it's awesome i think it's very
i mean who else is out there doing that
no that's the thing in this in the
skateboard industry nobody
i mean there's there's one other podcast
it's called the bun and they're really
rad they're doing what they do
um but no there's really nobody else in
our lane so it's kind of dope it's cool
it is yeah it's very cool like i said
it's just not soaking up knowledge like
wow this
this is the opinion of experts that's
how i'm looking at it right
you know right so good [ __ ] for you
that's awesome i think it's cool i think
it's
very cool and you're in another venture
of something you're not you weren't
comfortable with that first and now
you're like i like it
i liked it that's sick yeah definitely
it's been fun in the world man
fun [ __ ] podcasters are pretty fun man i
can't
i can't deny it so thank you so much i
want to say
thank you so much we're going to get you
out of here guys
um we appreciate you watching
i'm [ __ ] yes
thank you so much for watching um for
geron wilson on all social medias uh yes
everything yep okay also nine club on
was it youtube and twitter youtube
twitch instagram
uh oh twitch also yeah yeah what are you
guys doing on twitch um
we just started uh this thing called the
green room it's just another extension
of uh the nine club
and basically we just it's like a live
chat room so we go in there and just
[ __ ] answer questions and
shoot it up with the the community for
the most part sick man
so instant [ __ ] knowledge right
that's cool there seems to be they seem
to be liking it man it's still
the nightclub on twitch yep that's
awesome i mean good [ __ ]
are you on there are you guys all on
there or just we go on usually after you
after the experience on sunday evening
so we'll usually get on around like 10
give or take in the evening and we're on
for about two hours and like i said
we're just interacting with the
community and asking answering questions
and just
shooting the [ __ ] man cool man yeah sick
it's dope
well guys descriptions for i mean link
for the description
everything's going to be there thank you
so much for being here appreciate it
guys thank you so much for hanging out
thanks for watching another episode of
the dope as usual podcast
if you're driving please be safe you're
at home hang out have fun
thank you guys for hanging out with us
giving us your time i'm dope as yola
have a dope ass day oh yeah oh yo
that was dead i am i'm [ __ ] hot
i am [ __ ] hot
all right post read um i'm gonna move my
mouth and omar is gonna talk
omar you sit right here and you talk and
i'm gonna move my mouth
okay you do my ad read
i'm kidding you thought i was serious
you're [ __ ] up look how high he looks
what's up guys you have just finished
another episode of the dope as usual
podcast thank you so much for being a
part of it we appreciate it
we also want to thank our sponsors
stereo app if you don't know what this
is this is basically a way for you to
talk to us
marty and i part of the podcast if you
have direct questions or there's nowhere
else you're going to be able to go to
talk to us more intimately more
frequently and more
just personal this isn't a live chat
it's nothing like
nothing like that this is more of
a room that we can all talk to each
other and if you're not into the talking
you just want to listen and hear what we
got to say
it's just like the podcast this is an
extension of us go ahead and check us
out on the stereo app hit the link in
our description
if you're on spotify apple podcast um
iheartradio whenever you're watching
youtube
click the link below that's a stereo app
what you do is you when you click that
link download the app and follow us
that's our direct link
so two to three times a week i'll be on
there marty will be there sometimes also
this is basically what's gonna happen uh
maybe there's a topic we talked about in
the podcast or something that you
saw on the podcast you want to know more
about you can ask us directly
do you see what i'm saying this is the
this is the listener and
host directly talking to each other so
if you guys are fans you always you had
questions from years ago let us know
this is this is the app for it
do me a favor like i said click the link
below that's a stereo app download that
follow us i really appreciate it guys
that's dope as usual on the stereo app
thank you again for watching another
episode of the podcast have a dope ass
[Music]
day
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
bye